- Good morning Believe Nation
today's message is think big.
Over to you Vince McMahon.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- My dad was talking about selling out,
and that frightened me
because I didn't know
if I'd be a part or not.
So I knew there was just some way
I had to get my hands on this company.
- [Narrator] In front of his father
and a group of doubting investors
Vince works out a series of
convoluted business deals.
Somehow it works.
Vince and Linda McMahon now
own Vince Senior's company.
McMahon's vision is to create
a truly worldwide pro wrestling franchise.
- I knew my dad wouldn't have
really sold me the business
had he known what I was going to do.
And the vision of an
international point of view
of our business was nothing new.
I wanted to do that from day
one, my dad thought I was nuts.
And he was right really but
I didn't know I was nuts.
And then we just went
ahead about doing it.
- [Narrator] Vince McMahon,
working with his wife Linda,
begins building a national
and international brand
for wrestling, the WWF.
In the process he will nearly decimate
the existing wrestling establishment
in a controversial offensive
worthy of a military commander.
- He bring in his best wrestlers
into an area he was trying to capture.
He'd buy time and show videotapes
of their matches last week.
"And come to the arena,
come to the Colosseum
"this Saturday you'll see Antonino Rocca"
or whom soever he was pushing.
And he would take one at a
time, it was a blitzkrieg.
- My dad would get these
phone calls from his cronies
who had these little fiefdoms.
"Hey Vince, what's your kid doing?
"He's coming into my territory,
"he's going to wind up dead,
"I'm going to crush him like a grape.
"That means I'm going to
have to come to New York."
My dad was very very concerned.
And once he saw that we were succeeding
in head to head competition with them
my dad
began to
think, "Maybe this is
going to work after all."
- One promoter after another promoter
after another promoter.
And they didn't fight back
and they didn't coalesce
and they didn't come
together, they watched,
and threw up their hands
and ran like the dickens.
Not knowing he had a, no money,
and b, they could have won
and held their position, and Vince won.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
The question of the day today is
I want to know what your big vision is.
When nobody else is around, when you don't
have any of the
inhibitions, when you think
you can do big bold things,
what is that big vision that you
want to accomplish for
yourself, your business?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Michael Wohltmann from
pontevedrafitness.com.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really really
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
ya again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Hey believe nation if you
want some more motivation
on thinking big stay tuned
for some special bonus clips.
- Some of you all have a habit of dreaming
within your bank account.
Some of your thoughts
and visions are so big
and so outlandish and
so powerful and amazing
you'll end up talking
yourself out of that dream
from saying, "I can't afford that."
Well guess what?
There's a lot of shit I can't afford.
There's a lot of visions and dreams
that I still can't afford.
I've always had this idea
that one day I'm going to
meet a multi-billionaire.
And with this multi-billionaire
we're going to
become the best of friends.
And he's going to say to me,
"Tyrese, I got all the money in the world
but I don't have your
visions or your ideas."
And I'll say to him,
"I got you.
"I'm not going to lie to you,
I'm not going to waste your time.
"I got big visions and ideas,
I can't afford 'em all,
"but it's not going to stop me
"from having these visions and ideas."
I came here to remind you
that when people laugh
at your visions and ideas
it's only because they don't have
their own visions and ideas
around what they're supposed to
do with their life or their careers.
People that don't have
any dreams
for themselves
they tend to be dream killers.
People that don't have their own visions
they become vision killers.
They want nothing more than to talk you
out of your own visions.
They don't have dreams for themselves,
they don't have any
hopes, they're hopeless,
they're uninspired, unmotivated.
They have no dreams, they have nothing
that they're ambitious about.
But I want to remind you
to continue to dream
and dream big.
I have a habit of dreaming
with my eyes open.
I get very inspired by the things I see.
I'm inspired by architecture,
I'm inspired by photography.
I'm inspired by ideas,
I'm inspired by the idea that
someone can have a vision
and if that vision had
stayed in their mind
they would have robbed the
world of the opportunity
to experience that vision.
I mean think about this,
as big as this is,
the fact that it's in
the middle of the street,
if they had kept this
idea inside their minds
I wouldn't be here to look at it.
Or experience it.
This is the power of visions
and ideas,
right here.
Do you see it?
This is the power of not
allowing anyone to laugh at you.
When you say I want to build something,
a sculpture that can go in
the middle of the street
and it can be a iconic sculpture
that will last forever.
Long after I'm dead and gone this could be
a sculpture that can stand
in the middle of a street,
here in the streets of Paris.
And if this person who built this
would have allowed people to talked him
out of their dreams and their
visions it wouldn't be here,
for us to see or experience.
My voice is gone,
we had a sold out show here in Paris.
I just wanted to remind you
to dream and dream big.
And understand that your family
and friends and loved ones,
in most cases, boyfriends, girlfriends,
they will be the first
to try and talk you out
of your dreams, your visions and ideas
as to what you're supposed
to do with your life.
They will say, "Who wants you
"when you've already
had two or three kids?
"Who wants you when you've
put on all that weight?
"Who wants you when
you're looking like this
"and been through this
and been through that?
"Nobody's interested in you.
"Nobody's checking for you.
"They'll laugh at you,
they'll call you names."
Because they have no dreams,
they have no hunger for success.
They don't have an appetite.
They don't want it.
I want to win so bad,
my hunger and appetite for success
is intimidating.
It scares the shit out of people.
I come up with new visions
and ideas every single day
and people around me
say, "Slow down, stop,
"you're doing too much,
you're appetite is too big."
I can't help myself.
I want to build, I want to win.
I'm a billionaire.
I was a change-aire,
I was a dollarnaire,
I was a thousandaire, I am a millionaire.
There's only one step left.
The billion, I don't
think I'll see a trillion.
(chuckles)
But I know I'll see a
billion, I believe it.
I believe it and there's
no one in the world
that can talk me out of that feeling.
Sending my love all the way from Paris.
If you make it to the end of this video
I want you to write,
"Only those that can see
"the invisible can do the impossible."
You have to be able to
see what doesn't exist
in order to be able to pull off or achieve
what, in most people's minds,
seems to be impossible.
Only those that can see the invisible,
being able to see what's not there,
what is your vision, what is your idea,
what was that God sent dream?
Only those that can see the invisible
can do what seems to be impossible.
You have to be relentless.
You have to never let off the gas,
never stop, never quit.
Never allow anyone to talk you out
of the dream, the vision, and
ideas that God has sent you.
- [Narrator] At a compound
in Mountain View, California,
internet billionaire Naveen Jain
is hatching a plan that could make him
the world's first trillionaire.
- [Man] Naveen.
Good to see you my friend.
- [Naveen] Good.
- [Man] So Naveen the team is
working hard as it usually is.
- [Naveen] Of course.
- [Man] So we're going to land on the moon
somewhere around here,
close to where the Apollo
spacecraft landed at the equator.
- [Naveen] How did you pick that area?
- Well it's, first of all
it's on the near side,
so it's easily accessible from Earth.
It's an area, the dark
area, are actually regions
of lava plains, so
they're not mountainous.
- [Narrator] Not so long
ago it was the Soviet
and America's superpowers that were locked
in a race to land on the moon.
Now it's Bob and Naveen who
are leading the competition
to mine precious metals from its surface.
- Are we still on track to
land on the moon by 2015?
- [Bob] We're still on track Naveen.
- Initially we thought the mission
was going to cost us about $100 million.
Do you think we can bring the cost down
to say $50 to $60 million now?
- [Bob] Yeah, even less.
- Even less?
- I think the first
mission will be under 50
and subsequent missions
may be under 40.
- When would be able to tell your honey
that, "I want to take you to the moon"?
- [Bob] 10 years.
- 10 years?
- Not only will it be a honeymoon
but I can take you my honey to the moon
and I think that'll be the killer.
- If you can do that that's real business!
(bright instrumental music)
If we can go to the moon for $50 million
and the cost comes down
to 20 and we're able
to bring back the things
worth $500 billion,
I don't care what anybody
says that's a great business.
Somebody is going to
create a trillion dollar
industry in space and
we sure hope it's us.
When you tell somebody what you're doing
and they don't think it's a crazy idea
then you're thinking too small.
So when you walk up to a party
and people say, "What do you do?"
"Well I mine the moon."
"Well that's crazy."
"Well I'm thinking big."